[Music]
hello everyone so I don't know about you
but I have been to three different
arenas today I just thought I would
check them all out before coming here
you know so thank you for your patience
and thank you guys so much for
entertaining you while I was setting up
so we are talking about ES 2019 features
today how many people are using ES 2019
features now oh nice good I can I can
just show you something then right the
agenda that I want to go over today is
basically first I want a little
itty-bitty intro to give you a little
more information about Ekman script and
ACMA in general so then we'll talk about
the minor features the major features
and then I have a teeny tiny outro just
kind of you know clarifying that we're
gonna really focus on the features with
a little bit of information on back and
front who is this person running on a
stage and immediately yelling at you my
name is tara mexic I'm a developer
advocate at this great company called
progress Google developer expert help
start Cincinnati note school and women
who code and the mother of this awkward
ball of fluff Toshi Toshi m'gosh but as
of five months ago I am also the mother
of this adorable chunk of flesh Neko yes
I did poorly Photoshop my baby on to me
for a picture but but thank you don't
worry this isn't a Photoshop talk and
his thighs are actually that big those
are not photoshopped he'll be here today
so you can fact check me later but let's
go ahead and jump right in
I want to do a little bit of an intro
about ACMA
and Eknath script so like any good
superhero I feel that Ekman script has
an origin story and it starts out with
ACMA International which is actually I
learned doing this I never cared what
eka mustard for I probably should have
but I wanted to look into it now and
it's actually some of you may know this
it's European computer Manufacturers
Association
I am very glad that we shortened it and
this started basically in 1960 because
they saw how much we were using
computers and that it needed to be
standardized so that's where Ekman came
from and from then we knew we needed a
standardization for a java script and
that's where Ekman script basically came
into play and sun which is now Oracle
kind of had the the rights to Java have
you heard of Java No so they had the
right to that and that's that's probably
like the only association that you'll
see of Java and JavaScript and so since
that was taken they went with the
corresponding standard host a coma and
made ACMA script so now you know so like
a cup gun any superhero stories we also
have these pitfalls and weaknesses that
quote unquote build character right and
for Akuma script that was es4 abandoned
this was the version four of ECMO script
that there were just so many political
differences in the group that they just
abandon it they couldn't release it they
couldn't get past their differences
unfortunately and then another one is
what I like to call es6 years yes that
is the pun it took almost six years for
them to release es6 after the version 5
in 2015 so from about 2009 in December
to 2015 in June it's just how long it
took because it was so bloated there
were so many things they were so excited
to release to JavaScript standard that
it took quite a long time but again like
the superhero art
from those ashes we get some great
things for instance tc39 which is the
Technical Committee really started to
try to try harder to work together and
reform and do a lot of do a lot of work
to make smaller packages come out after
that es6 was so big they decided let's
do something more manageable like
developers right we break everything
into smaller pieces so it's more
manageable and that's what they did with
these new after es6 all the releases
after that were much more manageable so
just a real quick recap I just want to
say what the proposal process is because
we're talking about all Stage four
proposals and these I always think I
know what these mean and then I'm
dumbfounded when I get when I remember
the actual process of what these
proposals are because there's stage 0
which is the strawman freeform bringing
in the idea stage 1 because you know you
have to start at 1 because we're
programmers or I start at 0 sorry and
then stage 1 is the proposal where you
have the champion of that proposal come
in and advocate for this idea they bring
in API they talk about API is about
semantics and algorithms and then
version 2 is actually a version of what
will be in the specification and if it
makes it to stage 2 you have a very good
likelihood that it's going to make it
all the way through but yet there are
still two more stages Stage three is
it's mostly finished it's is the
candidate a stage and it's mostly
finished but needs feedback and this is
the one that's funny to me Stage four
which we'll be talking about is finished
and I have quotations around that
because at this part it's it's going to
it's ready to be included in the
standard but they need to get tests 262
acceptance they have to do this to spec
compliant shipping
the implementations need to pass the
tests significant practical experience
with implementation needs done and the
Ekman script spec editor must sign up on
the spec edit it sounds like a lot but
as we see we have a bunch of features
coming out and they did a good job
bringing them over to stage four so
let's go ahead and jump into the minor
features so first I just want to let you
know what we're gonna do is basically
give a little high-level what the
feature is the name of it who brought it
to who's the champion of it or the
champions and then a little code snippet
and then a little bit about the
compatibility so first we have trim
start and trim and has anybody here use
trim left and right oh nice some people
so this is a pretty self-explanatory in
a way it's basically taking white space
away from the left or from the start or
the finish it used to be called trim
left and trim right and that is
supported in many browsers but now this
is the new alias because not all
languages are you know have a left and
right or they have a left and right but
some have different ways of approaching
it so start and end just make much more
sense and then basically this helps you
kind of classify what is whitespace as
well whether it's a hard enter space
tabs so there's the whole process to it
but it is as simple as this you're
basically taking a string that has
spaces around it so a use case of this
is say you're filling out a form and
basically how it goes maybe in a CSV or
something you're getting too many extra
spaces so you need to trim it down you
get trimmed start and trim end so you
see start/finish space is removed and
then trim it takes both off and there
you can see the compatibility is pretty
good across the board
ie is a note who'da thunk um anyway so
simple prototype description this is
basically a string parameter that you
can pass on to
cymbal - and you don't have to convert
it anymore to a string and this
basically gives you the getter now for
the symbols description when they made
this it's basically their thought was to
help teams communicate across code and
communicate their intention for the code
and I read a comment by Josh gross Joe
gross Grossberg who was saying like
shouldn't we use documentation for this
so it may be polarizing which you figure
should you have Docs for this should
this be something in your code I always
figure the more places we can put
information that isn't comments the
better you be the judge so this is what
it looks like basically we have created
a symbol we pass in a string that is now
the description and when we log it out
we have symbol log that contains that
parameter or we can say use the getter
dot description and get just that string
this again is pretty available I got
these compatibility charts from mdn
because they fit really well in slides
but but some of the information wasn't
exactly right like this is available in
node 11 and they had it they had it as a
as marked as no but then I realized
above their compatibility charts they
have a link to github so you can correct
any compatibility errors that you see so
we have just have to be proactive okay
optional catch binding do a lot of
people out here use try catch much yeah
it's a we're supposed to write so this
is basically in your catch clause having
a parameter to bind bind to the
exception and a lot of people were using
this and throwing it away
because it would cause an error if you
didn't have this parameter a yeah a
common use case for this is say you're
using JSON parse and you know that it's
not it's going to throw error if it's
not JSON but you don't care about the
area you just want it to parse anything
that's JSON
so you throw it you log it you just
don't think about it so in their minds
this was superfluous right it was
something that you're writing is extra
keystrokes like who has time for extra
keystrokes right so they decided to get
rid of the per am and this ended up
being one of the most controversial
minor features but we will get to that
later
this is basically what it looks like
like I said earlier you're passing a
parameter to your catch clause and then
you know usually you'll want to log it
out or get that information do something
with it
now you can basically pass up that
parameter completely it is um it's again
you can see the chart I could also just
like pause and let you look at the chart
for a second instead of talking over it
but this is where you know that is is an
interesting situation when the most
active issue just says why it's like
okay
and it's so a lot of a lot of what I do
is read through issues be it like with
node modules or with Xmas script it's
really even just as associate like a
society like view in a society there's
some really really interesting thoughts
going into how we build our in
standardize our language like it's very
inspiring to see how much people care
about it
because we use it every day right so I
highly recommend looking into this but
basically how it started as the person
that opened the issue is saying that
they were pretty scared let me just say
what he said they were pretty scared
that allowing this may make devs forget
about error handling I mean does
everybody here do a good job handling
their errors silence so this is
basically he was saying it's making
production code untraceable and that he
thinks that errors should be logged I
mean we should be considering these
errors we shouldn't just be swallowing
them it could lead to just messy coding
irresponsible coding
and a few things of the comeback is
basically that this is making it more
intentional so if you're leaving off the
parameter you know you're leaving off
the parameter it could be even riskier
to leave it and so that people just
automatically throw that log and don't
think of it and there are some some
cases where you it's what you are
getting back you can't log or it is just
holds up the program so what you're
doing here is kind of taking the road of
you know the least evil one may say and
you're quietly swallowing your errors
and you basically your application can
perform its main job and you're not
compromising the ability to troubleshoot
like you can always add this it's not an
option that you can no longer add the
parameter okay so we'll go in a little
bit of a quicker pace to get you all
moving but prototype that sort is now
stable this is the Ekman script spec and
it made me immediately wonder what is
stable so this is basically it's a
stable sorting algorithm if you're
taking if you're looking at a list and
they have the two keys have the same
value they should after sort be in the
same order which I'll show you in the
code one quick note no pun intended but
this pond cut to the quick is intended
it's getting rid of quicksort and
instead using Tim sort which is made by
Tim Peters in 2002 and he's basically
making it more proficient but I want to
make sure I get this right he's using
binary insertion sort and improved
improving the merge sort which actually
allows it to work way better with with
arrays that are already sorted with so
it's a very interesting read and another
one that I highly recommend digging into
one day while you're waiting for the bus
or on the train but this is what it
looks like so you see here we have
multiple multiple valleys of a
that have varying values in this order
on top it goes ACB so when we sort it by
age we should get ACB in that same order
and it does it does that now or where so
there you go
moving on to major features again we are
going through this pretty quickly and
please feel free to come chat with me
after I love talking about this stuff
I'll even do another little talk with
you one but so flat and flat map is very
exciting is anybody using flat or a flat
map yet yeah right how how great is flat
map it's it's funny how exciting it is
to get like what features are coming out
next and flat map we're definitely one's
for me so flat is basically its
recursively concatenating to the array
dependent on how many in your parameter
how many levels you're telling it to go
down and its base and then flat map very
simply putting it's kind of taking map
and then flat so your mapping through an
array and then flattening it flattening
it to a single level array but of course
there is more to it with map you are
getting exactly one output element it's
a it returns a single value and with
flat map it's translated to zero or more
output elements the interesting thing is
it can also return non array values but
that is less common then there is my
favorite part of it which is smoosh gate
didn't anybody hear about smoosh gate so
I mean okay again we go to the tea after
the code so first of all with flat in
general so you see we have an array with
a nested array with array inside of it
so there's three levels here so if we
just do flat it defaults to one layer
and we have that array that's still
nested in there but if we pass two to
that original array it nests it all down
or flattens it all down to one and then
with
map you're basically with map you get an
array of arrays flat map you can get
back just a flat array of those so
smoosh game the thing to me about smoosh
game is this to me is like a visual
representation of when I tell really
corny knock-knock jokes like there are
74 thumbs down on this guy's joke so
poor Michael and he's he's actually the
one that is brought is the champion of
flat flat map or one of the champions
and so what happened here is mootools
had a polyfill of flatten and they
wanted ACMA script wanted there to be
flattened as the name of this feature so
I took my husband's also a programmer
and I told him about this and he was
like what's mootools which is a lot of
people's reactions so basically you know
you're taking kind of legacy code and
it's stunting the progression of what
people consider the progression of code
so there was a lot of discussions around
this basically making sure that we are
adapting correctly that we're not
leaving anybody behind so they changed
it from flatten to flat as we see now we
have flat and flat map and there is no
smush there was never a smoosh there may
still be a smoosh but probably not
compatibility wise this is where it is
available all right last but not least
we have object from entries I actually
used I'm a big fan of object at entries
but object from entries is taking a list
of key value pairs and converting it to
an object which is the opposite of
object entries but these siblings
actually work really well together and a
good representation of that is XOR Meyer
in his
is duality calm website he actually
looks at object entries and object from
entries and utilizes them to recreate
different functions from underscore and
I'm a huge fan of that when I saw the
article I was really excited because I
was trying to explain to someone how one
of the biggest points of advancing the
language of making the standard is we
make all these shortcuts or I would
hardly say shortcuts actually very
intricate libraries to make up for what
we may see as shortcomings into the
JavaScript language to do the job that
we need to do and so underscore was one
of those libraries and again not a
shortcut lots of work lots of really
great work in the underscore library and
now we see when we bring something to
the language like a object from entries
how we can advance the language to then
make it so we wouldn't need this other
library and this is what it looks like
basically we start with an object that
has key value pairs when we do object
out entries and pass that object in we
can get an array of arrays and that
helps us iterate through there use all
of our array functionality on it and
then when we want to take it out of
there and treat it as an object we do
object out from entries and put those
entries in to create the object and this
is where that is available again it is
available on opera no matter what mdn
says and then real quick we won't go
over these but again if you want to have
a lunch conversation with me I there
some really interesting things I found
out digging into the looking into well
form json stringify that json super set
which in somebody was saying some when
people in spanish-speaking countries say
json some day say jota stone and i think
that's beautiful
so I just had to pass that on but anyway
then there's also the prototype to
string revision with looking into these
I dug into Unicode in ASCII a lot and
there's a lot of really cool history to
them but for now I will just do a little
teeny tiny intro to say that
the stage at 1400 hours you will get to
see the amazing tc39 part of the tc39
group to answer all of your questions
that you may have about what's coming
what have been how to use things and
their decision-making and I also just
want to I know I personified these two
groups as superheroes
but I am indeed very grateful that they
put the time and energy into basically
giving us a better coding experience or
at least you know putting their efforts
into trying to give us a better coding
experience and make JavaScript better
for us so I am very grateful and I am
very grateful that you are all here
today so thank you all very much thank
you
[Music]